Now, the network section of the cash manifest contains files
that explicitly needs a network connection. Foe example, we can't
really cash the google-analytics page because the connection is important.
If you have a image resource that's a live webcam
image or some other kind of data that has to
be loaded over the network, putting that resource in this
section will bypass the out cash. And try loading the
resource from the network, even while it's offline. And finally,
the Fallback section is where you set up alt
cache alternatives for resources that need to come from the
network. For example that live webcam image. Maybe you want to
cache an old version of it. The browser will use
the rules in this section to load an alternative.
But only after trying to load the resource from the
network first. For that reason you should use the Fallback
section sparingly because it will await for a network timeout.